for the world cup i'm planning to do we
are planning on the team jungle book and
jungle book has Mowgli the boy this is
him so we're going to do something like
this for the competition sitting on a
piece of rock and this is completely yes
it's purely made of chocolate 28 year
old meanie and her team have been
practicing every weekend for months the
rest of the time they teach at the
academy of pastry art in a suburb of New
Delhi that's also where meany completed
her own training ten years ago in the
asian qualifying rounds team india ended
up in the top three of 12 teams securing
them a place in the world cup final in
france for the first time meany is
responsible for everything made of
chocolate i love chocolate.i de slovakia
chocolate eating chocolate especially
and and the joy that you get after you
finish working with it is is it good I
mean it's a different high the chef's
must present the judges with structures
made from chocolate ice and sugar along
with the usual cakes and desserts
they're working to strict deadlines and
each step of the process has to be
executed to perfection you cannot give
99% you have to put in hundred percent
to give a good product even if that
cherry on the cake is not at the right
direction it wouldn't look pretty
meanies team often uses fruits that are
readily available in India they have to
order many of the other ingredients
online cakes and pies are a rare
delicacy in India baking isn't part of
the country's tradition top hotels
employee pastry chefs but they're mainly
from Europe when I speak to a French
pastry chef age as me
he's been seeing his family big from the
time who's 4 years old he's picked up
baking trays from the time he was two
and three and four easy baking around
him from the time he was a kid the world
cup is a chance for me to prove that
India can bake to every other year the
world's 22 best teams square off against
one another at the world pastry cup in
Lyon
[Music]
the competition climax is in a
spectacular display of sugar work and
chocolate sculptures it's India's turn
tomorrow meanie and Mukesh are scouting
out the competition so many mixed
emotions and excited no is so many I
cannot explain such a dream wearing the
Shepherd
cook them on the official jacket wins
[Music]
it's the next morning shortly before
seven the teams have been working for at
least half an hour only mini Mukesh and
yogesh are allowed in the kitchen the
judges top criteria include of course
taste but also the organization of
teamwork and the mastery of individual
techniques
nothing gets past these guys
how did the judges rate India's chance
of victory before Mike's if they're
really giving it all they've got you can
see that we hope it pays off but the
first time in the competition is really
difficult it really is the best of the
best it's the highest you can get now
for the taste test India's frozen
dessert is up the judges cast a critical
eye over the construction before they
assess the flavor so the name of the
desert of tv3 is that Wishing Tree
nested approaching a delicious and
creamy vanilla bean ice cream layer
between the ice cream is a tart
strawberry cream the 24 members of the
panel are all specialists each one
tastes and evaluates 44 cakes and
desserts every day the individual scores
are kept secret until the winner is
announced back in the kitchen Team India
is building up the intricate sugar and
chocolate sculptures for the final
display arranging the pieces takes a
steady hand meanies Mowgli figure is
hollow one slip and he could shatter
into pieces it's crunch time everyone is
on pins and needles as they await the
verdict who will be crowned world
champion
the host country friends takes the title
for the eighth time
in the Oval head home empty-handed but
for meanie this is definitely not the
end everything
there is no place on the podium for them
this time but meany has fulfilled one of
her dreams she is officially one of the
best pastry chefs in the world